[Musique]
on s'apprête à commémorer le centième
anniversaire de la naissance de de
frédéric dard puisque c'était le 29 juin
d'ailleurs la ville des bureaux ville
dans laquelle j'ai vécu pendant une
vingtaine d'années avoir d'aidé des
animations il y aura des films vers une
exposition etc
mais nous allons parler avec quelqu'un
qui l'a bien que du c'est fred hidalgo
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes vous
êtes journaliste vous êtes écrivain vous
êtes éditeur et vous êtes tu es un ami
un très très proches amis de san antonio
puisque on verra tout cela mais il nous
a donné le surnom de le plus fiable de
mai fait ou alors un bouc corruption
vous vous êtes dit journaliste éditeur
écrivain spécialiste de musique vous
avez créé par les musiques vous avez
créé chorus oui vous avez écrit la
biographie de jacques brel notamment
après son départ pour les marques et
pour les marquises aller sur goldman
devrait aussi être un des grands
spécialistes de da de la musique de la
chanson 1
mais là on va parler d'autre chose de
frédéric dard que vous avez rencontré il
était tout jeune il faut que nous
raconter voulu écriviez vie de l'être
vous avez vous êtes quoi lui un instant
nous de san antonio j'en ai lu 4,4
d'affilée c'est à dire que depuis
quelques temps alors j'ai j'ignorais
totalement qui se cachait derrière sur
antonio j'ai pensé que c'était son idée
géniale 1 voilà je pensais que c'était
san antonio tout simplement
et puis depuis un certain temps vous
savez à l'époque le fleuve noir avaient
installé des tourniquets et c'était un
système génial de diffusion pour toucher
le plus grand public il avait des
tourniquets qu'il mettait partout dans
les maisons de la presse bien sûr dans
les gares mais surtout dans les
épiceries campagne partout et il y avait
un tourniquet pas très loin de chez moi
heureux
j'habitais à dreux et où il y avait bon
tous les bouquins du mois de fleuve noir
tous les mois ce été renouvelé et
notamment des san antonio alors déjà le
titre le nom de
l'auteur m'avait un peu interpellé et
puis surtout les couvertures il faut
rien cacher des couvertures c'était
bourdon l'illustrateur du fleuve mais à
l'époque c'était bon genre des
couvertures plutôt à guichen ne assez
sexy et c'est bon et puis lorsque vous
étiez gamin j'avais 15 ans et 15 ans à
l'époque et on est en 62 64 clarins à
l'automne 64 et il a fallu que je tombe
mal pour ne rien vous cacher j'avais les
oreillons j'étais confiné et à ce moment
là l'écart 10 sont talonnés à l'époque
1,06 et raffiné et les 400 antonio qui
trônait dans ma bibliothèque
j'en ai pris un et puis un deuxième et
un troisième et un quatrième ça a duré
comme ça moi serait pas lâché 3 4 jours
et nuits d'affilée c'était un choc un
choc esthétique que j'avais ressenti
jusque là qu'avec que pour la chanson
avec brel quand on n'a que l'amour et la
san antonio alors son style la rigolade
évidemment le côté outrancier et puis
surtout moi c'est ce qui m'a frappé tout
de suite c'est les interpellations aux
lecteurs il faudra si tu toi même le
lecteur vous avez l'impression enfin moi
j'avais l'impression à 15 ans qu'il me
parlait vous parlez est ce qui a été le
cas de tout le monde en fait de tous ses
lecteurs c'était son génie c'est que
tout d'un coup ils arrêtent et irrigue
il partait dans des digressions il
s'adressait aux lecteurs moi je suis
fait comme ça quand j'aime quelque chose
j'ai envie de le partager et de le dire
et en l'occurrence je ne savais pas
qu'ils partageaient j'avais aucun
lecteur de faire antonio dans mon
entourage
donc je me suis dit je vais lui écrire à
lui puis lui dire que c'est formidable
alors j'ai écrit à monsieur san antonio
aux bons soins de son éditeur le fleuve
noir boulevard saint-marcel rabhi sur
san antonio l'a hélas il faut dire
pardon pour les gens qui ne seraient pas
que le loto c'est frédéric dafa son vrai
nom c'est frédéric va affréter saignée
en effet un certain nombre de livres
la plupart de ses 1 900 d'entre nous il
a ici on en parlera peut-être tout à
l'heure signé des livres frédéric bard
oui bien sûr et elle est la hausse des
prix vers san antonio j'étais alors
antonio alors à l'époque soit antonio
s'était déjà quelqu'un de très connu
dans le monde de l'édition il avait une
mais mandoline avait déjà beaucoup de
succès oui il y avait beaucoup de succès
déjà depuis 5 6 ans et à côté il y avait
frédéric dard qui publiait ses romans
sous son propre nom qui était beaucoup
moins loin du rendu et puis qui surtout
était beaucoup moins connu est minime de
lui même faisait là le distinguo il
tenait à faire le distinguo il voulait
absolument pas qu'on sache que c'était
lui qui écrit mais san antonio
oui il voulait pas que ça c'est pour ça
qu'ils procèdent au corps absolument
qu'il a trouvé comment il a trouvé dans
un dictionnaire il a trouvé aux mureaux
dans son bureau des mureaux avec sa
femme qui était là et donc il prend une
chez sa femme lui dit tu devrais faire
du policier d'accord j'ai inventé un
héros comment il faut l'appeler il prend
une mappemonde
et puis bon le jem est fermée les vieux
avec mon doigt je met mon doigt sur la
main bandée la pelouse de san antonio
sur 120 lots d'un texas lozé paris s'est
dit non c'est pas bon parce que je
voulais à un non américain c'est pour ça
c'était t'es pas là maintenant tu t'es
la carte de cassini ouais c'est ça et à
l'époque c'était peter chesnais voilà
tous les jeunes gens tous les auteurs de
polars de l'onu c'était une société d
état américain ou alors devra mériter
cette lettre alors je lui écris une
lettre et je lui dis à peu près ce que
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que
l'opération le lit qu'il écrivait pour
moi qui s'adressait à moi que c'était
vraiment j'avais jamais autant ri de ma
vie en et puis qu'il y avait plein de
mots que je découvrais que je ne
connaissais pas mais qui est vraiment
dont on deviner le sens coin 20 par
rapport au contexte de la phrase est
tout bon ce style déstructuré et j'ai
tout mis en bloque quoi dans une longue
longue longue l'homme est forcément
parce qu'il a dû en recevoir d'autres
dons qui a forcément dû être touché par
cette lettre parce que et combien de
temps six mois après mois raconté ce qui
vient vous voir
alors sept mois après et maintenant
parce que là moi je lui envoie ça parce
que j'avais besoin de l'emsa mais je
m'attendais pas spécialement intéressé à
une réponse mais il n'y a pas de réponse
et si les six ici un mois après je
reçois une réponse alors signé san
antonio il n'avait pas d'adressé et puis
il me dit cher monsieur
les lettres l et quelque part j'étais
très touché par vos mots et je terminais
en lui disant je sais que vous venez de
sortir un hors série
c'était l'histoire de france au centre
d'antonio formidable formidable c'est le
record de vence de vente 1964 le livre
qui s'était plaint conseiller même au
temps et aux lycéens qui veulent réviser
l'histoire c'est génial sauf moi j'avais
lu que les petits les quatre et je
terminais en lui disant j'ai vu vous
aviez publié un hors-série la gemme
précipité je le commander chez mon
libraire et y terminer en disant que dès
que vous aurez lu l'histoire de france
dites moi ce que vous en pensez d'accord
je lui ai répondu et là il ya une
correspondance qui a démarré pendant six
mois
d'accord et au bout de six mois je
reçois un petit mot alors dans
l'intervalle
c'était plus les lettres sont antonio
sans adresse était devenu frédéric dard
les gros mur les mureaux avec le numéro
de téléphone avec son adresse et son
téléphone 578 lancé l'époque soutenu et
il m'envoie un petit mot en me disant
j'ai envie de vous rencontrer téléphoner
mois un matin de cette semaine et c'est
alors à l'époque projeter les loyers
chez mes parents
donc j'attends de sortir de l'école ou
non c'était un jeudi à vrai dire
j'attends le jeudi c'était le jeudi jour
de congé à l'épaule et je vais à la
poste on n'avait pas le téléphone on est
en 65 à ce moment là est très très bon
téléphone mais c'était compliqué de
l'avoir jetée conduite et de l'avoir
l'époque il fallait vraiment un sandre
et donc je vais à la poste et puis voilà
il décroche et il me dit ben cheikh j'ai
envie de vous rencontrer à l'acide de
correspondance
si ça vous va je peux passer dimanche
prochain à dreux pour mouvoir et 1 voilà
de dimanche qui arrive voilà alors je
suis rentré chez mes parents j'aurais
dit ça le soir il ment pas cru bon pas
cru mais le dimanche ils arrivent ils
arrivent à la maison à l'heure dite
était 10h30 à peu près il arrive avec sa
femme et sa fille directement depuis les
mureaux incroyable est incroyable
vraiment ils savent si vous aviez 15 ans
non il ne le savait pas oui pour c'est
peut-être vous est il plus âgé que ça
voilà alors à un moment donné c'est vers
la fin de de son passage chez mes
parents il ya ma mère qui s'adresse à
lui ai dit monsieur d'art d'après ces
lettres quel âge donné vous à mon fils
et frédéric répond je lui donnais 4 à 50
plus l'âge de mon fils à peu près et qui
était étudiant et donc ils pensaient que
j'étais étudiant seconde à l'époque en
troisième et bon voila il avait été
touché par ma lettre au point de vouloir
venir me rencontrer et à ce moment là
pour que l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là
parce que je me suis dit ils auraient pu
très bien
oui vous vois c'était fini quoi et je
les dis et monsieur d'argeles appelé
monsieur d'art et qu'est ce que vous
penseriez si je crée un club sont
antonio et il me dit pourquoi pas si ça
permet de réunir mes lecteurs et que de
rigoler ensemble pourquoi pas et donc
deux mois après parce que faire on était
le dimanche 13 juin 1965 quand il est
venu et deux mois après au mois d'août
je crée le club san antonio dont qui
était le premier la première association
des amis de san antonio il très vite ya
eu trois parrains qui auraient été les
trois acteurs qui ont joué dans les deux
films san antonio qui ont été tournées
en 66 et 68 de dire gérard barré d'un
rôle devant antonio qui était connu pour
ses rôles de cape et d'épée du mans jean
richard joris à petit vers une
dérouillée et puis paul préboist qui a
joué le rôle de de pino vie nouveau
troisième
oui alors ça c'est des personnages de
son opinion et donc est née à partir de
là une amie qui est quoi oui absolument
c'est à dire qu'à partir de là on s'est
vus revus va pas la fois suivante
alors oui c'est quand même quelque chose
à la fois pour moi c'est un grand
chagrin et en même temps quand je le
raconte aujourd'hui ça paraît incroyable
pendant l'été il me demande de le
rappeler et il me dit est ce que ça te
dirait de venir déjeuner à la maison aux
mureaux donc j'étais content comme tout
et il me dit je dis oui forêt mais il
faudrait que ce soit un jeudi ou le
dimanche
forcément tu veux jeudi 30 jeudi 30
septembre cette barbe parfait bon ben je
dirais tu attendras la gare génial
c'était le jeudi 30 septembre et je vais
pour prendre mon train donc il était
10h30 11h à la guerre de droits pour les
mureaux meulan les mureaux et je passe
c'est devant la maison de la presse
et là il y avait des placards devant la
maison de la presse frédéric dard le
père de san antonio s'est pendu c'était
aussi sa tentative de suisse et 59 ça
alors
65 65 c'était dans la nuit du 28 au 29
il a tenté enfin oui l'attaqué de
suicide et là c'est quoi pas ce qui est
je crois qu'il est il a rompu avec sa
wii cette fameuse à l'époque un en fait
il avait une liaison depuis quelque
temps avec la fille de son éditeur mais
avec laquelle il avec lesquels ils à
vivre à se marier entre guillemets la
fille de la femme de sa mort oui est bon
il
ils avaient du mal à quitter c'est un
dilemme cordes et j'ai atterri pour lui
et voilà il nie les faits cette
tentative de suicide voilà mais c'était
quelques il faut dire peut-être parfois
bipolaire pour le dire il sait pas si
c'est exactement mais c'est vrai que
c'était quelqu'un qui avait acquis à une
littérature qui plus tôt et très enjoué
très drôle mais c'était pas forcément un
personnage toujours très nord contre 21
un vrai pessimiste et aujourd'hui même
il exorciser sa part une des détails et
jubilatoire qui faisait rigoler tout le
monde est en fait il était profondément
pessimiste
en gros lui sa philosophie c'est vrai
pourquoi est ce que l'homme est là en
train de se faire du mal quoi se taper
dessus
alors qu'on a tous un destin tracé
on commence à mourir le jour on vient au
monde existant de neydens était c'était
oui devant une philosophie un peu
désespérée avec nature dans fable
absolument que musicienne et vous
parliez des apostrophes qui fait aux
lecteurs dans dans ses romans il
expliqué au fond je veux pas qu'il soit
court quoi mais il essayé quand même
voilà il se doit d'être assistée vous
êtes
ça je vais essayer de vous changez pas
infaillible un peu ça c'est exactement
ça il s'est battu toute ma vie contre la
connerie leila sans guillemets et mais
en espérant justement donné des armes
pour lutter contre parce que ce qui
était bien chez lui c'est qui s'excluent
et pas du lot ils se mettaient pas sur
un piédestal disais bon non absolument
on est toujours sûr mais voilà il
donnait des piles seront feuilles
rapport à sa manière évidemment ça
venait avec son génie drôle mais c'est
vrai que il avait au fond il avait il
n'aurait pas aimé qu'on ne le
comprennent mal quoi qu'on en lisant un
aspect parfois il ya des personnages qui
peut être raciste qui peuvent être vissé
l'isf ou 2 quad a dû complètement lui
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est vrai que on
vit dans une ère en ce moment du
politiquement correct et donc si on
prend certains de ces lits où il ya un
hors-série de san antonio qui s'appelle
bérubé rue qui se déroule en afrique
noire
ou alors c'est la grande rigolade mais
bon certains esprits étriqués pour
épurer l'eau comme blanche-neige bruit
l'un de ses adjoints c'est jérémy
blanche une cena specter noir qui arrive
du sénégal il est à paris il travaille
ses tableaux et puis c'est lui qui
l'intègre dans son équipe qui finalement
devient presque son successeur il ya une
tendresse énorme avec lui comme les
c'est vrai que je croque un hors-série
du point notamment enfin découvrir
actuellement il s'interroge sur est-ce
que vous pourrez est ce que les san
antonio pour être publiés aujourd'hui et
des questions qui se posent sur la vraie
question qu'il faut comprendre le
deuxième degré aussi exactement
exactement lui il a toujours travaillé
au deuxième degré 5ème certains
humoristes sur l'offre de rôle des
proches
c'était cette époque là et alors il ya
un livre de ce vote il s'appelle ceci
est bien une pipe c'est son dernier
c'est l'avant dernier en fait oui oui
c'était même et laura à la page 56 j'ai
dit ça
je connaissais la chanson paroles et
musique comme dirait mon cher fred
hidalgo c'est donc vous le plus fait al
de meuf et où c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure et je le proclame ici
grand connétable de la santonnière riz
alors les comédiennes rhioui titres dont
il pourra se parer sa vie durant et sur
ses pieds aborder ces petites fées vous
êtes vous est cité en tant que voix la
fraise d'albums c'est à dire il m'a cité
plusieurs fois tant subi naya on a vécu
en afrique avec ma femme à un moment
donné il m'a fait un clin d'oeil il m'en
a dédié deux autres mais dans celui là
donc c'était pour les 50 ans de son
antonio en plus ce qui correspondait à
mes 50 ans remet à moi parce que je suis
dit en notant que c'est antonio san
antonio est né aux mureaux et puis moi à
dreux donc à 60 km de distance et donc
dans son antépénultième chez l'avant
avant dernier en réalité ça antonio en
gros il me bon c'est pas à moi de le
dire mais il veut consacrer le proclame
la meule et son lecteur le plus faible
de monsieur oulaï fidèles
c'est plus grand connétable de la sarthe
où les riches me suis dit mais c'est une
grande responsabilité est à dire qu elle
est à moi de porter la part d'une
ancienne menace possibilités il faut
dire peut-être c'est une oeuvre
considérable 7 280 roman plus une
vingtaine de pièces du théâtre plus des
scénarios de cinéma dire que c'était
avec avec simenon pratiquement et demi
qu'ils disent que des c'est bien sinon
lui a confié l'adaptation de sa première
pièce de droite la neige était fall
absolument c'est les plus prolifiques
cofondé des auteurs français a fait ses
conseils alors ils avaient ils avaient
un rituel c'est à dire que il écrivit
chez lui mais je crois qu'il mettait son
pouce à sa veste sa chemise sans cravate
oui pour aller taper à la machine
laguiller ils s'habillent effective en
cours pour travailler je sais pas s'il
l'a fait toute sa vie mais en tout cas
dans le moment il fait partie de sa vie
a été sa wii le rituel costume cravate
pour aller travailler c'est comme s'il
allait au bureau quoi absolument oui
alors la différence est que lui
l'écriture c'était quelque chose qui
s'était lié intrinsèquement à sa
personnalité
je ne sais pas combien de fois il m'a
dit il a dit à tous les journalistes qui
l'a rencontré mais si j'arrête d'écrire
je meurs oui je crois que voilà c'est à
dire qu'il terminait à san antonio
aujourd'hui et se remettait le lendemain
matin il commencerait le suivant et
quand ils nous avaient percé cette
imagination nous ça venait comment
comment commence à bild et parce
qu'elles font à la mairie nation est
extraordinaire d alors je vous parlais
du rendez vous manqué
le joyau prenons pas ce que je faisais
interrompu c'est là ce que vous voyez
ces affiches
qu'est ce qui me fait donc voila ce
moment là j'ai cru qu'il était mort
carrément le père de san antonio s'est
pendu quand j'ai acheté le journal à
l'époque c'est françois rey l'aurore je
me souviens j'avais gardé et j'assure
entrait je ne vais pas aller jusqu'à 6
min route non non non je suis revenu à
la maison c'était jeudi donc j'ai
attendu que mes parents rentrent du
travail le midi et on a décidé de
téléphoner à
darwin et odette à l'époque sa première
femme haut aux mureaux donc on le
connaissait puisqu'il était venu avec
frédéric et elle nous a dit que tout
allait bien
enfin qu'il était restée dix heures dans
le coma donc l'avant veille et c'est
pour ça que le lendemain ça commençait à
filtrer dans la presse et que donc deux
jours après quand je m'apprêtais à
l'airé chez lui mais déjà les journaux
et nous a dit mais les médecins disent
qu'ils doivent qui doit subir une cure
de sommeil parce qu'il était
complètement
enfin il travaillait trop quoi ils et
elles
elle nous a fait comprendre que c'est
que c'était son rythme de travail
effréné là il avait conduit voilà est
sûre de burnout voilà une sorte de
burnout bon là dessus après moyens il ya
aussi voilà la recette très sûrs avec
cette dalle et condamne fortement il ya
eu charrier la rencontre et il a aidé en
suisse d'ailleurs oui alors et un mois
je les revues
deux mois après donc face à 36 ans elle
est mieux
et puis il m'a envoyé un petit mot et il
m'a invité à déjeuner mais alors au
fleuve noir
à paris vers la fin octobre début
novembre
donc deux mois après la tentative de
suicide est là bon j'étais évidemment
très gêné j'avais 16 ans simplement mais
bon j'ai pas pu m'empêcher de lui dire
que j'ai cru qu'il était mort voilà et
puis manière il m'a expliqué les choses
et il m'a dit bon maintenant on n'en
parle pas voilà c'était alors et il m'a
expliqué les choses parce que deux mois
après il m'a invitée sur l'île saint
louis à paris où il avait pris un duplex
et où il vivait à d'accord avec
françoise donc ça qui allait devenir sa
qui allait devenir sa deuxième femme et
avec laquelle il va s'installer donc en
suisse suisse
après il ya des périodes des épisodes un
peu dramatique comme l'enlèvement de
joséphine sa fille l'avez vous l'avez
oui c'est à ce moment là oui oui parce
que là on peut raconter elle est enlevée
en suisse il ya même un nom je crois
qu'on en à l'enregistrement du dialogue
qu'il a avec ravisseurs oui oui en fait
à des parents quoi c'est un jeu le fric
je te le donnerai c'est marrant moi ma
fille
oui oui absolument mais ils étaient
désespérés parce que c'était donc sa
nouvelle fille
il avait eu une
elisabeth et patrice de huy de cette
première phase et puis ensuite il a eu
une petite fille qui s'appelait
joséphine est là qui était tout jeune et
c'était vraiment il l'adoré en plus il a
toujours adoré et donc c'était comme lui
arracher le coeur vraiment et non qu'on
lui a demandé une rançon colossal mais
quand il est parti en suisse il s'est
installé à gstaad il s'est fait
construire un chalet ni d'abord il est
en location est hélas il vivait à genève
où sa fille a été enlevée par ce qu'il
venait de vendre son chalet donc il
avait l'argent en banque
il a demandé à son banquier de débloquer
le dos des ensembles voilà et donc il
est à lire il s'agit de marion face aux
besoins
oui oui je vois que c'était dans ces
deux millions de francs suisses 2,3 c
était vrai que c'est un épisode alors ce
qui est le plus incroyable ça s'est bien
passé parce que la police suisse
voilà ils l'ont retrouvée saine et sauve
voilà pour faire rester une blessure
énorme chez frédéric mais alors le plus
incroyable c'est qu'il était en train
d'écrire un livre où il racontait un
enlèvement qui est un livre fabuleux en
plus pour moi c'est son chef-d'oeuvre
c'est une sorte d'appel alors il
s'appelle faut-il tuer les petits
garçons qui ont les mains sur les
hanches
c'est signé san antonio mais sans les
personnages de san antonio
c'est à dire que depuis février y avoir
un nom il ya deux trois ou quatre ans
auparavant
son éditeur ça a été un coup de
marketing mais c'était la réalité en
même temps avait publié un livre qui
s'appelait y at il un français dans la
salle qui était tourné par jean pierre
mocky à l'écran est hélas c'était le son
éditeur lui ai dit écoute il faut le
signer son antonio parce que là tu t'es
vraiment laisser aller comme jamais ça
n'est pas un frédéric dard
c'est pas non plus un san antonio de la
saga avec les personnages mais tu l'as
écrit comme un san antonio donc on va le
signer san antonio et on va annoncer
enfin frédéric dard et san antonio ont
tempéré leur jonction à
et à partir de là il n'a plus jamais
signé frédéric dard toujours sa antonio
dont faut-il tuer les petits garçons qui
ont les mains sur les hanches et là ils
font héros c'est un auteur de romans
policiers dont il parle comme étant
l'auteur de bourgoin jallieu les fils
aîné à bourgoin jallieu
frédéric dard est né à bourgoin jallieu
et il est il écrit à ce moment là le
rapt de la belle-fille pas sa fille mais
de la belle-fille de le do not there
croyable et et l'huile en train d'écrire
ça quand sa fille dont on écrit ça c'est
incroyable alors sur le coup il s'est
dit mais j'ai c'est moi qui attiré la
foudre est il abandonné son livre et
finalement il a repris un an plus tard
bon il disait qu'il lui faisait des
signes dans le placard où il avait
remisé et il a repris mais en mettant un
petit mot c'est ici que l'impensable
s'est produit
voilà les le l'enlèvement dans dans la
fiction est dans la réalité il nous
reste malheureusement plus de temps on
serait resté un grand désert avec vous
et vous allez d'abord peut-être publié
un livre il y avait un livre qui était
prêt qui sera publiée prochainement se
ressent on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
comme s'il sortira bien sûr et puis si
si pour les jeunes générations par
exemple si sir voilà quelqu'un qui
voudrait découvrir san antonio lequel
quel niveau on considérait alors bon il
y en a beaucoup on l'a dit c'est à
l'heure il ya quelques 200 san antonio
avec les hors séries et c'est pas loin
mais finalement le premier hors série
l'histoire de france je trouve ça génial
génial parce que effectivement on
retrouve l'histoire de france mais
aménagé un faux-rythme savoir un
grossier
alors le fera savoir les allures les
blessés c'est le stand un bond à rire
oui non mais pour tous les hors séries
dans a sorti six ou sept
il y en a qui s'appelle les cons mais
les cons sans s parce qu'en fait c'est
une famille et à partir de là on peut
extrapoler
nord il faut lire il faut le lire pour
lui il faut pas être rebuté sa théologie
ce vendeur de livres 250 millions sont
claires il faut dire simplement que
fadil un styliste voilà ce que peut-être
pour conclure un oui c'est un des grands
stylistes du 20e siècle
voilà ça c'est pas moi qui le dit tous
les grands spécialistes l'ont dit entre
rabelais et céline modération 13 mn par
céline oui pour lui c'était un choc le
voyage c'est un choc
et puis rabelais bon depuis rabelais
c'est soit en tenue ou indirectement
personne d'autre merci beaucoup
mercredi la gauche merci merci
[Musique]